inflation has hit record highs the
taliban is chasing the united states out
of afghanistan the american population
is dying and hunter biden lost another
laptop full of compromise to the
russians according to a new video of him
complaining to one of his hookers
thank goodness the adults are back in
charge i'm michael nolsas the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from philip
portolano who says screw your freedom
this guy sounds like the governor of
california that's true arnold
schwarzenegger does sound like the
governor of california you know
the parties change the people change and
yet
the liberal establishment continues to
rule it's something that could make you
lose sleep at night and if you are
losing sleep at night i would strongly
recommend you check out bio optimizers
you know it's very important to get good
sleep especially when you've got a
screaming little baby in the background
you've got to try to maximize your sleep
one of the best things you can possibly
do to improve your health is to get
seven hours at least of quality sleep
every night it's very difficult i know
no one can do it
one of the biggest reasons that you
might not be able to get that sleep
other than a screaming baby might be
magnesium deficiency magnesium is key to
getting good sleep but 75 of people are
actually magnesium deficient is it any
wonder that so many people have sleep
problems well to help fix those sleep
problems and to fully enjoy the calming
effects of magnesium check out magnesium
breakthrough by bio optimizers it's the
only organic full spectrum magnesium
supplement that includes seven unique
forms of magnesium you just take two
capsules before you go to bed you'll be
amazed at how much better you sleep and
how much better rested you feel when you
wake up marie for example left a
five-star review she said she'd give it
a hundred stars if she could she went
from daily struggles and restless legs
horrible terrible sleep to no struggles
with any of that so go check it out
today magnesium breakthrough is 100
organic made with vegetarian non-gmo
ingredients give it a try check out for
yourself why so many people are raving
about magnesium breakthrough for an
exclusive offer for my listeners go to
magbreakthrough.com forward slash
knowles knowles10 that is the code that
you got to use knowles 10 use it during
checkout to save 10
should we start with the hooker
let we should let's do it let's start
with the hooker
because the adults are back in charge
you see everything was going terribly
under trump and the economy was great
and our geopolitics had settled down and
american confidence was growing again
and manufacturing was great and wages
were up and inflation was down but
but then the adults got back in charge
and now
and now hunter biden has lost another
laptop uh this is a pretty crazy story
so it just came out it's a video of
hunter biden
speaking to one of his hookers for some
reason he
videotapes all of his crimes and so
this video has come out this was from a
few years ago and he is complaining that
some russian drug dealers stole
a third laptop of his filled with a
compromise and he doesn't know where it
is take a listen
what does the computers have to do
they have videos of me doing this
their videos
crazy
because they've got videos of me doing
crazy ethics
yes
he also knows that i make like a
gazillion dollars they'd try to
blackmail you
so here we go everything
everything that was reported in the new
york post before the election
that the liberal establishment the
politicians at big tech and the media
told us was not true
not only is it all true as as we always
knew but we now have video of hunter
biden admitting that it's all true in
one conversation with a hooker so he's
actually showing you that it's all true
while he's saying it's all true this is
the third laptop that's gone missing
thank goodness
that the adults are back in charge i
would recommend to hunter that he
stopped recording himself committing all
of these crimes but this is a this is a
very big problem because if don jr blew
his nose the wrong way it was a
international news story and it was the
disgrace to the united states but hunter
biden you don't hear anything about this
he's admitting that he makes a gazillion
dollars how's he making a gazillion
dollars he doesn't have any skills and
he doesn't work so he's obviously making
a gazillion dollars by selling his
father's name and trading on his
father's influence in the u.s government
are they going to blackmail him he's
admitting that they're going to
blackmail him who is it it's the
russians we were told for the entire
trump administration that
he was compromised by the russians it
turns out actually
it's the bidens who are compromised by
the russians and where is this now we're
not hearing anything about it when you
tried to not only post this on social
media during the election but even
privately message it you were not
permitted to do that this is being
completely suppressed by the
establishment well what does it mean
what does it mean what is being done
right now because of this blackmail
speaking of the birds and the bees
speaking of the birds and the bees
the american population is dying people
are not having babies anymore this has
been a trend since the 1970s but it's
really ticked up in recent years and one
of the reasons for that
is
climate hysteria which by the way you
know i hate to say that i told you so i
called this years ago and i talked about
it a few months ago again on the show
people are so ginned up about the sun
monster and they're so afraid that the
the sun monster is going to kill
everybody that they're actually right
now not having children they're not
growing the population well it turns out
that analysts even from highfalutin
investment banks agree with me a recent
investor note from morgan stanley
analyst said quote the movement to not
have children
owing to fears over climate change is
growing and impacting fertility rates
quicker than any preceding trend in the
field of fertility decline so this this
hysteria about
about the weather killing everyone
is is causing a decline in fertility
more than stagnant economies
more than wars more than the last
environmental scale a scare that that
nonsense about overpopulation that
cropped up in the 1970s that turned out
to be completely bogus
the the united states birth rate last
year
fell by four percent
four that's a huge number everyone said
there was going to be a covid baby boom
i actually participated in what there
may have been of the covet baby boom my
cute little baby is evidence of that but
as a population matter it actually fell
by four percent
uh that means that regardless of all the
other issues we can worry about you know
immigration wars the economy all this
the country is literally dying there are
just
fewer people being born and this is
affecting different demographics
differently speaking of population
decline it turns out that the white
population is declining precipitously
the the share of the white population in
this country fell
for the first time in american history
it fell from 63.7 in 2010 to 57.8 in
2020 that's the lowest on record it's
because of falling birth rates
specifically among white women uh
compared to hispanic and asian women
the number the number just the raw
number of white people non-hispanic
white people shrank from 196 million in
2010 to 191 million today
and as you might expect
liberals are celebrating this which is
so funny it's so funny because i don't
know if you've been paying attention to
the news over the past six or eight
months
but there is this new narrative in the
news that
if you observe that
the
white the white percentage of the
population and the raw number of white
people is shrinking that you are a
conspiracy theorist you're a racist
you're a white supremacist they call
this the great replacement crazy
conspiracy theory and you're basically
no better than hitler if you suggest
that
but if you're a liberal who acknowledges
all these things and celebrates it
that's very good
jennifer rubin who used to pretend to be
a conservative columnist at the
washington post now i think she's
basically open about being a liberal
columnist she tweets out this article
and she says quote a more diverse more
inclusive society this is fabulous news
now we need to prevent minority white
rule
of course it is
cliche i shouldn't even say it i'm so i
don't even want to say it but of course
if any columnist said this about any
other racial group they would be called
a vile vicious racist and rightly so but
jennifer rubin because she's saying it
about white people is not called that in
that imagi i can't i hate this because
truly conservatism is going to die
because we keep playing these
hypotheticals and say well you know if
the shoe is on the other foot but you
know if she tweeted out
because the let's say the black
population was decreasing a more diverse
more inclusive society this is fabulous
news now we need to prevent minority
black rule obviously she'd be run out of
town uh should she'd have her entire
career destroyed but because it's
against white people it's perfectly fine
jennifer rubin is not the only person
saying this you hear it actually from
elected democrats ilhan omar just some
months ago came out and said this
is not not going to this country is not
for white people and white people better
pack up and head on out this is not
going to be the country of white people
uh so and there are so many more
examples of this
so from what i can conclude if you say
that
white people are diminishing as a
portion of the population and you
suggest that either that's neutral or a
bad thing you're a vile vicious
conspiracy theorist racist if you make
the exact same odd observation but you
celebrate it you are a good wonderful
person who supports diversity and a
thriving america uh probably not
probably not great
for our country to have
elites
cheering on the decline of of a large
segment of the country probably not the
best thing for the country as well but
speaking of records don't worry
don't worry about that that'll be a
longer term sort of issue
the shorter term issue is that the
prices are going through the roof on
just about everything because inflation
is hitting record highs probably makes
one want to make sure that uh one can
keep track of his possessions which is
why i would strongly recommend
ring knock knock who's there
i don't know you don't know you don't
know because you don't have ring that's
the problem you've got to get ring and
then you'll just know who is outside
your door whether it's the delivery guy
whether it's a burglar or whether it's
your mother-in-law who are you less
excited to see i'm not so sure with ring
alarm you can keep an eye on your
doorstep whether you're in the home
whether you are at the office whether
you are on the other side of the world
but it's more than just the doorstep you
can keep an eye on every
inch of your home with rings so it gives
me peace of mind especially when i go on
the road which i do a fair bit
it gives me peace of mind for my friends
when i give it to them as a housewarming
present mostly because it's not that
expensive but also because it's a very
very good product
go check out ring today you can install
it yourself keep an eye on every corner
of your house
ring.com
knowles go there for a special offer on
a ring alarm security kit you can build
a system that's right for your home have
it up and running in minutes that's
ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles
inflation for businesses so we're not
talking about inflation generally we're
just talking about inflation for
businesses costs for businesses
have reached a year-over-year rate do
you want to guess do you want to guess
what inflation was for businesses last
year
what would you say two percent
three percent
seven point eight percent in july 7.8
this is the highest level
ever recorded
you'll recall in july president biden
put out a tweet and he said happy fourth
of july you're so lucky that i'm the
president now because the cost of your
fourth of july barbecue has decreased by
16 cents they actually put this out
so it's decreased by 16 cents cost of
everything else is up 7.8 percent but
you know hey at least you saved 16 cents
so the bureau of labor statistics showed
that this producer price index not the
consumer price index but the producer
price index which tracks changes in
input prices for the businesses and for
domestic producers has increased
just this month by a full percent so
inflation going through the roof
inflation generally including for
consumers
also is up at recent record highs the
inflation rate in july remained at 5.4
percent
that matches
june's
levels
uh year-over-year inflation
in june obviously reached 5.4 percent
this is the highest rate since the great
recession that began
in 2007 and 2008. it's not just
republicans who are worried about these
scare statistics even some democrats are
doing that including joe manchin
so joe manchin who i think may be the
last semi-moderate democrat in the
entire country kirsten cinema the
senator from arizona a little bit as
well but basically mansion as far as i
can tell there are three groups in the
democratic party now it's the
progressives it's the super progressives
and it's joe manchin those are the three
factions of the party joe manchin asked
the federal reserve to stop printing all
this money because when you just print
money endlessly eventually you're going
to get some inflation
the the federal open market committee
which oversees the execution of monetary
policy has refused to amend its near
zero interest rates or scale back its
120 billion dollars in monthly asset
purchases here's what here's what joe
manchin said to the fed he said quote
the record amount of stimulus in the
economy has led to the most inflation
momentum in 30 years and our economy has
not even fully reopened yet
i am deeply concerned that the
continuing stimulus put forth by the fed
and proposal for additional fiscal
stimulus will lead to our country
overheating and to unavoidable inflation
taxes that hardworking americans cannot
afford so this ends up being a tax
not on the rich not on the people who
need to pay their fair share this ends
up being a tax on everybody and it
disproportionately hits the middle class
and working classes so
really bad situation for americans who
were already feeling the squeeze because
the government wouldn't let them go to
work for a year
also and i suspect this is a little bit
of what joe manchin is seeing here when
we just print money
endlessly
when we just uh inflate
inflate the dollar or inflate inflate
the economy
this weakens our argument against china
right so we make this argument against
china we say china
is uh is illegitimately uh manipulating
its currency
that's a very bad thing it shouldn't be
doing that we're doing the same thing
china is
uh
violating various sort of trade
agreements uh okay well if if we're
tinkering with our economy in this way
we're doing
similar sorts of
measures well china this china that
china this china that
there's a there's a great old blues song
sort of popularized in the last few
years by eric clapton before you accuse
me take a look at yourself and that's
what joe manchin is doing that's what
republicans are doing right now
but
it doesn't matter we're just going on
and on and on china's spying on its
citizens yeah we would never do that
right the united states would never oh
it turns out actually the nsa is spying
on tucker carlson and
every gizmo and gadget that we have is
spying on all the rest of us including
our microwaves and our refrigerators
china has a social credit score oh yeah
we would never have that right we would
never ostracize people and de-platform
them and take away their ability to use
financial institutions and put them on
the no-fly list just because they're
political dissidents right oh wait a
second we're doing the exact same thing
really weakens our argument on the
foreign stage
and speaking of our adversaries
we're looking really really weak on the
foreign stage right now because i
mentioned this at the end of the show
yesterday
we just officially lost the war in
afghanistan
soldiers didn't lose the war soldiers
did a great job soldiers are the
toughest fighting force in the world but
the political leadership did and now
we're being chased out by the taliban so
the united states
is evacuating afghanistan the united
states
is pulling out somewhat rapidly under
joe biden this sort of began under trump
but it's it's continuing under biden
and as the united states leaves the
taliban is just coming back and and
taking over all these cities much faster
actually than
joe biden told us what happened so
actually now the the united states needs
to send 3 000 soldiers back into
afghanistan just to make sure that our
embassy officials and our
remaining soldiers and our translators
aren't slaughtered by the taliban before
they can all get out
afghan government forces
according to the associated press are
collapsing even faster than u.s military
leaders thought possible
the taliban which ruled the country from
1996 until
after the united states invasion after 9
11 has captured three more provincial
capitals wednesday probably that number
is even higher now i haven't checked in
the last hour
the 10th and 11th
cities that the insurgents have taken in
a week-long sweep that has given them
control of two-thirds of the country
which is more or less what they had
before 9 11. joe biden of course the
adult in charge
finally we've got stable leadership he
told us that this was not going to
happen
how serious was the corruption among the
afghanistan government to this mission
failing there
well first of all the mission hasn't
failed
yet
there is
in afghanistan
and
all parties there's been corruption
the question is
can there be an agreement on unity or
purpose
what is the objective
for example it started off there were
going to be negotiations
between the taliban and the afghan
national security forces
and the afghan government
that
that
didn't come to
didn't come to fruition
so the question now is where do they go
from here
that the jury is still out but the
likelihood there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely highly highly unlikely it's
highly unlikely
it happened immediately but it's highly
highly unlikely oh this will just two
weeks to slow the spread oh hunter biden
didn't lose his laptop to the russians
oh
this that
and the other thing is it any wonder
that these people
have no
credibility whatsoever don't worry
though don't worry the united states has
a strategy they know how they are going
to stop the taliban from overrunning the
country and undoing 20 years of whatever
we've been trying to do in afghanistan
do you know how they're going to do it
it's not the 3000 troops that's just to
get our guys out of there without them
being slaughtered the way they're going
to do it and this is really i did not
expect this strategy
they are going to tweet
at the taliban
taliban known for its twitter presence
they're going to tweet snarky hashtags
and that that oh
you thought 20 years of military action
and occupation was going to do it no no
the twitter hashtag will quote this is
from the u.s embassy in kabul
escalating taliban violence including
executions of surrendered afghan troops
shows a lack of respect
for hashtag
human rights
don't erase afghanistan's human rights
gains of the last 20 years
yeah what are you going to do with that
taliban
yeah what are you going to do with that
huh
you know frankly i wish i wish that we
had known about this in 2001 and 2002. i
guess twitter didn't exist in 2001 and
2002 would have saved us a whole lot of
time and money and treasure and blood
and effort in afghanistan to accomplish
as far as i can tell
absolutely nothing
this is very sad this is very sad
for american servicemen who served in
afghanistan
what
was accomplished
the one thing you could say was
accomplished is that we killed osama bin
laden
but we got him in pakistan we didn't
even get him in afghanistan we got him
many years later but okay let's say
that's it you go you kill osama bin
laden great so
so what are we doing i i guess
in a moment of candor if you really if
you got a few drinks in the state
department officials who have been sort
of managing this thing or the pentagon
officials
probably what they would tell you is
we're just treating afghanistan as a
sort of overseas imperial territory and
we're just going to be there and we're
just going to kind of manage it
they probably wouldn't tell you this on
television because i don't think the
american people want an overseas empire
in afghanistan and by the way
afghanistan is known as the graveyard of
empires
but to what end what
what's the point what does victory even
look like the united states has not been
able to define that in
at least a decade at this point
and so now we pull out
having accomplished very very little
because the adults are now in charge
what time is it what a lot of people are
waking up to what time it is one way you
can wake up to what time it is is with a
movement watch i love
a good time piece i love a good wrist
watch i have since i was eight years old
and i got my first watch and i have
loved them ever since and i do have a
fair number of watches and
you know i just got two more movement
watches yesterday i did movement man
they are changing the game in a tiny
apartment in southern california two
college dropouts teamed up to create a
watch company that broke all the rules
they had fair prices unexpected colors
really clean original designs movement
grew into one of the fastest growing
watch brands shipping to over 160
countries around the globe they also now
have blue light glasses which are great
they protect your eyes from screens
they've got minimalist jewelry they've
got a lot of style essentials that won't
break the bank you get a beautiful watch
shipped right to your door for free if
you don't love it you ship it right back
no big deal go check it out i really
love their automatic watches so it's got
an automatic movement that so you don't
need batteries or anything but the
battery watches are great too i really
love my movement watches if you want to
elevate your look with style that
doesn't break the bank join the movement
15 off today with free shipping and free
returns go to mvmt.com knowles that's
mvmt.com
knowles
a lot of
really embarrassing stuff happening
right now for the united states
obviously on the foreign policy front
obviously on the economic front
obviously the population is literally
dying that's not good
and
if you ask the democrat ruling class
for an answer for all of this madness do
you know what they're going to tell you
they're going to tell you
they're doing great they're going to
tell you don't believe your lying eyes
don't no actually do you know people
are actually just envious of the way
that democrats are running this country
so wined
governor gavin newsom of california just
the other day
well let's talk about what we also are
number one and stephanie
and guys forgive me i know i'm a little
pointed today but i've been taking a lot
from
a few folks
for a lot of months so it's nice to be
able to express myself too
but i do with deep
pride in this state
as a california not as a i'm a future ex
governor it could happen in a few weeks
could happen a few years
i love this damn state we're number one
in job creation tenfold the american
economy 559 000 jobs eat your heart out
texas florida it'd be damn nice
if our homegrown team start focusing on
what's right
everybody outside this state
is big about this state because of our
success and i'm proud of it i'm not
naive about our competitive
liabilities and that's why we're trying
to address them
yeah that that's why that's why
everybody's talking about california is
because of your success your success at
spiking the crime rate your success at
having record levels of homelessness
your success at such extraordinarily
high taxes and regulations that not just
conservative businesses like my business
that moved out of here that's why i now
live in tennessee but even liberal
businesses are fleeing the state because
they can't do business anymore your
success at locking people in their homes
shutting down their churches
completely upending their way of life
meanwhile subsidizing crime all over
this that's why that's why everyone
is fleeing your state he's obviously
feeling the heat right now
and he's feeling the heat because you
had a couple of candidates who were sort
of unknown little-known republicans in
california who were not going to pose a
big challenge to gavin newsom as a
recall effort then you had the bruce
jenner thing which was obviously a
sideshow it was one of the greatest
gifts you could possibly give the
democrats that bruce jenner running and
splitting the republican party
but then you had larry elder throw his
hat in the race
and larry elder is a pretty mainstream
guy and larry elder's got a lot of name
recognition and larry elder can raise a
lot of money he's been raising millions
and millions of dollars and larry elder
is very likable and larry elder is quite
conservative though you know you know
he's still somewhat libertarian he's
still a little bit more in that
acceptable moderate california wing he's
a real candidate is what i'm saying
and gavin newsom is obviously feeling
the heat from that and so
i think this performance that he's put
on is a combination of genuine
desperation but also some campaign
advisor saying gavin you got to get
tough people want you to be tough and
it's not working
very very well and it's not working well
not because of the the lack of a
performance you know gavin newsom is a
slick politician he's obviously made it
very far he's talented as far as
politicians go
it's not working because
at a certain point you can't deny
reality
at a certain point
the liberal establishment which
controls the media controls every form
of communication
it lies and lies and right now it's
lying about covered numbers among
children hospitalizations among children
that's another story that just came out
the reason for this of course is that
one of the arguments against forcing
kids to mask in schools and forcing
young kids to get the vaccine is that
the virus doesn't pose a particularly
lethal threat well now major news
organizations are having to admit that
they're actually inflating the numbers
of of child hospitalizations from kovid
because that would be a way to promote
this narrative but even that's falling
apart because we've got eyes and we see
what's going on and we see what we're
paying at the grocery store and we see
what we're paying at the gas tank and we
see our troops being chased out of
afghanistan because of failed political
leadership and we we just see it we just
see it we see the crime on the streets
in l.a my name i lived in a pretty nice
neighborhood in la had a little tiny
apartment like a lot of people do in l.a
but it was supposed to be a nice
neighborhood it became a homeless camp
by the time i left even then every other
neighborhood basically was like that
so it's it's just
they just can't sell it anymore aj even
even when they try to effect their plans
their schemes in the dead of night
even that i think people are keeping
their eyes open especially
senator cruz senator cruz
i don't just say it because he's a
friend of mine i don't just say it
because we host a show together he did
some
truly magnificent senatoring
this week
and it happened in the dead of night so
a lot of people didn't pay attention to
it there was a bill it was the number
one priority for democrats hr one the
first house resolution and s1 the first
senate resolution it's called the for
the people act that's what they call it
it's really the corrupt politicians act
it's a way to federalize federal
elections or federalize rather
congressional elections and some others
and uh take away election integrity
measures and just try to make it so that
politicians can't be booted from office
and chuck schumer because he's a really
smart clever politician and a good
tactician
he tried to ram this thing through in
the dead of night and he very well could
have gotten it through you needed one
objection to stop it
and senator cruz because he's a little
bit i say this with great love he's a
little bit of a nerd he knows the rules
he knows the way these procedures work
senator cruz caught him and he stood up
to offer that objection and he
single-handedly stopped
possibly the most corrupt legislation
that's gone through the congress in in
my lifetime
this bill would constitute a federal
government takeover of elections it
would constitute a massive power grab by
democrats
it would disenfranchise millions of
americans
and it would do precisely the opposite
of its
nominal title for the people it would it
is instead for the politicians
because it entrenches politicians and
ensures that the people cannot vote them
out of office
it would strike down virtually every
reasonable voter integrity law in the
country including voter id laws
supported by the overwhelming majority
of this country including prohibitions
on ballot harvesting again widely
supported by people in this country it
would mandate that felons be allowed to
vote and it would automatically register
millions of illegal aliens to vote it
would profoundly undermine democracy in
this country and for that reason i
object
for that reason i object a lot of things
going terribly wrong in this country but
there are a few people paying attention
a few and all it takes is a few
well-organized people to fight back
against this sort of thing to fight back
against what you might call the
authoritarian moment
that's the title of ben's new book
available at amazon barnes and noble any
other major bookseller get your copy now
it's a great book to order after you've
ordered my book speechless it's a really
good i would say ben's book is the best
second book that you could order on any
of those websites also if you sign up
now as a daily wire member with code vip
you will get 25 off your new membership
you'll be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two to the
daily wire studios in nashville to see
candace live not only will you meet
candace herself you'll get an insider
look at her studio front row seats to
watch your show live
that's dailywire.com subscribe with code
vip to get 25 off be automatically
entered for a chance to win that vip
experience
also you can subscribe and listen to
morning wire it's our new morning show
it's like npr but we tell you the truth
you know so it it's like it's like the
new york times is the daily except it's
not full of lies you just but it's got
that same really nice soft voice hello
good morning welcome to the morning wire
and you know it's got all the just the
news stories in 15 minutes but the the
distinguishing feature is that it's uh
it's not not extremely dishonest like
those other left-wing ones so head on
over go subscribe we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag josiah writes dear
michael my wife and i have been married
for 10 years we have a nine-year-old
daughter we've made it this long but we
disagree on politics and religion
stuff i'm a conservative and she's a
liberal though she says she believes in
god she has no interest in praying going
to church or reading the bible with me
as our daughter has gotten older we've
clashed more and more regarding what and
how we want to teach her and it's
becoming very difficult to find common
ground any thoughts thank you
well
you're in a tough position
and you're in a tough position because
the answer to your problem actually lies
in a kind of broad world view and
specifically
in religion
and because your wife and you disagree
on that
really what you're saying is you
disagree on marriage itself because
conservatives have generally speaking a
different view of marriage than liberals
do and christians certainly have a
different view of marriage than modern
secularists do and so
the the short answer to your question is
you need to be the head of your
household
and this entails you loving your wife
this entails you being a good steward
loving your wife as christ loves the
church which is no no small request
but it also
gives you the responsibility of making
these sorts of decisions and leading
your household however
your wife may disagree with that because
your wife
is more liberal and because perhaps your
wife is irreligious though perhaps maybe
she would say otherwise so
it remains true the only way out of this
is for you to lead your household and to
either through persuasion or confidence
or just plain old-fashioned leadership
persuade your wife you know bring your
wife along on that but but it's very
important that you
give your daughter a view of the world
your daughter's going to have some view
of the world she's either going to have
your view of the world or your wife's
view of the world or some completely
separate view of the world but there's
there's no
middle ground between i'm a christian
and i'm an atheist there's no what the
middle ground is like
buddhism i don't i don't know there
isn't a middle ground you just have to
make a decision i know that we're all
very nice these days and we all want to
just get along with everyone and no one
wants to say no to anything but
no some things are true and some things
are false and some things are good and
some things are bad and some things are
right and some things are wrong and you
you have to come down on the side of
that
and it's very hard because by the way
when we say that the husband has to be
the head of his household this is
generally speaking not something that
men are clamoring to do i think there's
this idea that men are all just knuckle
dragging monsters who all they want to
do is boss everyone around like caligula
or something but it that isn't the case
in my experience and knowing my friends
as well mostly what men want to do is
lie on the couch and eat potato chips
that i would say that would be the main
thing we want we don't actually want the
responsibility of making all of these
decisions i get into this
disagreement with my wife sometimes and
she's always right
we'll be talking about okay we've got
one night off we maybe there's a
babysitter or something we're gonna go
out to dinner
what do you want for dinner i don't know
i don't care maybe but you want italian
maybe time maybe do chinese i don't know
what do you want what do you want what
do you want what do you want we'll go
back and forth for about
15 hours on this question what do you
want what do you want and eventually
she'll say hey head of household make a
decision already genesis 3 get it done
let's go man up
and she's right
but i don't want to do that and very
often very often men don't want to do
that but you got to buddy so i
i wish you luck because it's a i don't
mean to make light of your situation
it's pretty tough but uh that's what
you're called to do from sarah one of my
friends is a transgender woman
i so meaning he's a man who now
identifies as a woman i use his pronouns
to his face but the rest of the time
like now i call him by his proper
pronouns he's a very good friend and
i've been able to tolerate his
transgenderism because of that he sent
me a text last night saying he just
scheduled his appointment for gender
reassignment surgery that is to say
genital mutilation up to this point
i've kept my mouth shut because i really
can't stand to watch him make this
horrible and life-altering decision how
should i approach him about this
i care about him and i don't want to see
him hurt himself but he seems pretty
dead set on it thanks so much facing the
trans factor trademark uh tough
situation actually related i guess to
the previous question which is
sometimes love requires people to
say difficult things
i'm always reminded of the bio tapestry
which is this wonderful art piece about
the battle of hastings in 1066 and
there's a great panel on it where it's a
man holding a club and he's smacking the
other men on the head and it says here
bishop odo holding a club comforts the
boys
we don't think of comfort as smacking
someone on the head with a club but
that's what he was doing because the
boys were retreating and odo said no you
got to get back into the battle and
sometimes we have to say harsh things
coincidentally i actually have a column
coming out on this in the daily wire
today which is related to texas's
decision to classify a trans surgery for
kids as child abuse and i said that's
good i'm glad they're banning the trans
surgery for kids
now we ought to do the same for adults
and the reason for that is not because i
want to prevent people from following
their hearts and their dreams and their
passions but it's because
the the genital mutilation of
transgender surgery is harmful it's
wrong it isn't right it is not good for
anybody even the people who are
suffering with this delusion that you
know they're women even if they're
actually men
it's not good for anyone that
we're calling it child abuse not only
because the children can't consent to it
but because it's an actual mutilation
and so it remains in mutilation for
adults and so what i would recommend you
can send your friend my column when it
comes out
but you can also turn him to people who
have had immense transgender regret i'm
thinking of people like walt heyer he's
he's become pretty outspoken about this
he was a man who suffered from sexual
confusion and gender issues
all the way back until he was four years
old and then at the age of 40 he began
his process of identifying as
transgender he
transitioned you know he had the the
mutilation at 42
and then
it didn't solve his problems for a brief
period of time he thought it did but it
didn't solve his problems and then at 50
he transitioned back and you're seeing
more and more stories about this a lot
of young people are transitioning back
this is a hideous
faddish ideology that is overtaking
people and
i think it's
certainly akin to the the performance of
lobotomies in the previous century you
know all these quack medical procedures
and so i do fear that your friend will
regret this and i think you ought to
just you ought to just tell him that and
part of the confusion might be that
you've indulged his delusions until now
but i i don't know that it's an act of
respect to indulge people's delusions in
this way i think it might actually be
more respectful and be more of an act of
love to tell them what you really think
from camille
dear mr knowles with all of the dating
advice or tips that exist today one that
keeps popping up is that men will
immediately put women in a box
of whether they would date this woman
just want to hook up or have nothing to
do with them is this true that guys
immediately categorize the women they
meet and there isn't much a woman can do
to change how the men perceive them
sincerely nobody puts baby in a box
it is true that men put women in a box
it is also true that women can do things
to change this perception
so they can do things in their general
behavior if a man walks into a party and
sees a woman doing a keg stand
you know in a bikini being held up by
the four brawniest members of the
football team
he's probably not going to immediately
think this is wife material i want this
woman to raise my
children
now it may be the case that plenty of
women have done this at some point in
their lives but they don't you know you
don't want that perception always to be
out there
that would be the first part of it
also it can be the case that let's say
you know that the guy sees the girl
doing the keg stand with like 15 dudes
like grabbing under her legs and they
they hook up but then
later on he realizes this was actually
sort of an aberration and this does not
represent her general disposition and
personality
i have seen
i have seen one night stands turn into
weddings i i have i've and actually good
marriages too so
that can happen as well but you should
be
cognizant of the and i know this is very
politically incorrect but you should be
cognizant of the fact that your behavior
will play a role in this it's not just
the terrible men and you know they're
not feminist or woke enough it's your
behavior too that will that will play a
role in this we all make judgments on a
level that is not always totally
conscious based on what people are
wearing based on sort of behavior people
are engaging based on the circumstances
in which we see people and so if you are
more interested in getting married than
just hooking up
which
is a good idea
then you should be cognizant of that
when you go out when you dress when you
put yourself in situations from evan
hello mr knowles i will be visiting
family for the first time since coming
out as a conservative and voting for
president trump in 2020. do you have any
tips or tricks to help me get through
this i won't go looking for trouble but
i also won't sit there and take the
attacks i greatly appreciate your advice
and i love the show thank you it can be
a little tricky because
the left is more vindictive than the
right
the left is more likely to instigate a
political fight at a dinner table than
the right this is always the case the
reason for this by the way i'm not even
saying it's because of something that's
gone totally broken in their souls it
may may or may not be but there's a
cultural aspect here too which is that
liberalism is the culture that is the
dominant culture so
when you dissent against that you're the
weird one
you are looked on as the heretic
and because the liberal establishment
has all of the power they're just more
likely to
to feel ready to to go after you and to
persuade you so i would i would
recommend
sure don't just take it don't say
something that you don't believe
obviously but i would do it with a smile
on your face and i would do it you know
i would jab a little bit more than i
would throw a right hook i don't think
right hooks are great for the dinner
table but little jabs can be perfectly
fine if
if your relatives are really going after
you for this you know
you might mention the fact that uh
hunter biden is a criminal degenerate
who has given our our enemies lots of
compromi and he's at least as corrupt as
well obviously they're much more corrupt
than the trump
family but
equally corrupt perhaps to the clinton
family oh right that other major
democratic family you know you you can
get these little jabs in here
of uh
you know if they say oh everything's so
much better under body you say yeah you
know it was until i went to fill up my
gas tank yeah it was until i went to go
by was until i went to go to
go out and live my life i mean there are
all these but i wouldn't throw that
right hook though because don't forget
the purpose of a family event
is not to win a political argument the
purpose of a family event is to be with
your family and to have a family and so
don't take it but keep in mind what what
the goal is from garrett dear quoter of
famous theologians
for years i've noticed that that quotes
from various historical figures such as
saint augustine or c.s lewis just roll
off your tongue do you prepare these
quotes in advance or are they just
stored in your mind if stored how did
you compile such an array of quotes and
how might you advise one to follow suit
sincerely would be learner of famous
quotes
well you know winston churchill said
that if a man lacks an education he
ought to get a good book of quotations
and this is true this is very important
i don't prepare them for the show i do
just have a lot of quotes in my head
in part this might be because i had a
somewhat insufficient education and so
i've really gone looking for little
pearls of wisdom elsewhere
and you should do it too part of it is
at least when i was in school maybe it's
still true we had to memorize poetry i
also
had worked as an actor before and i
always loved that craft as well and so
memorization is is a skill that i've
worked on a lot you can work on it too
one thing i would recommend is just
memorize a poem every few days it seems
kind of weird i know but it's easier to
memorize poetry than it is to memorize
prose
obviously because there's a rhyme and
there's a meter and a rhythm to it
and
and then just you know when you when you
come across a good line if whether
you're reading it or whether whether
truly whether like churchill you've got
a book of quotations
just
record it highlight it underline it
because it really can
beef up some of your arguments when
you're having you know if i say for
instance this is my view on taxation uh
because my buddy joe schmo said so or if
you say this is my view on taxation
because saint augustine said so that's
obviously going to be more persuasive so
just as a as a tactic i think it can be
very helpful and well worth your time
all right that's it that's our show see
you monday i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode a
battle over masked mandates erupts in
texas oregon schools make big changes
over alleged racism and a hollywood me
too group is caught up in a me too
scandal join us and get the facts first
on the news you need to know with our
show morning wire